times of need we have celebrities here
to help us welcome to another tone
another installment of tone deaf
celebrities thinking that they matter
this is a video called uh i take
responsibility
so why don't we just play it
i take responsibility
i take responsibility
i hate him i hate him i hate him i want
to like aaron paul so much i want to
like him man he's such a good actor but
he is such a pompous [ __ ] every time
he's not acting they can't keep getting
away with it i hate him
focus mike this is a i'm starting it
again you know focusing on how real this
is
i take responsibility
i take responsibility
i take
ketchup responsibility
i take responsibility who's that
i don't know any stop asking me cash i
knew before before this i don't know
this is amanda pete it's like a vulcan
was amanda pete though when i got yelled
at for not knowing
[Laughter]
for every unchecked moment for every
time it was easier kristen bell i like
her too i think she's funny and um they
all they're all [ __ ] scum they're all
garbage you really gotta
all of us you gotta stop liking
celebrities just just like the movies
and the shows right or to ignore than to
call it out for what it was
every not so funny joke
every unfair stereotype
every blatant injustice no matter how
big or small
every time i remain silent
hey didn't didn't your co-host um
co-host didn't you didn't you one of the
actors uh
your friend that you called him your
good friend in uh the league didn't he
lie about being at ground zero on 911
that was different dude
oh
every time i explained away police
brutality
stop trying to stop trying to
rationalize it dude are they apologizing
for stuff that
they never did no rice they're not
apologizing they're taking a situation
that has nothing to do with them and
making it about them this is what they
do and there's ron howard's daughter
here
they do is ron howard's daughter
or turned a blind eye
i take responsibility
black people are being slaughtered in
the streets
[Music]
by other black people
so so do me a favor
why don't you tell the black guys to get
with the other black guys and tell them
to cut this [ __ ]
i mean
right that's a statistical fact right
black people are being slaughtered in
the streets objectively speaking yes
by other young black men
killed in their own homes these are our
brothers and sisters our friends it's
khaleesi
family
we are done watching them die not
khaleesi is that not khaleesi
you sure yeah her eyebrows are too light
they all look the same to me i don't
know i'm racist about white women i
don't know what to tell you my friend we
are no longer bystanders
we will not be idle oh good you're going
to finally get active and get involved
and speak out more oh good because doing
that if there's one thing i've been
saying lately is like jesus man
celebrities have really not attached
themselves to every relevant topic
lately
enough is enough i will no longer allow
an unchecked moment
i will no longer allow racist hurtful
words jokes stereotypes no matter how
big or small no hold on hold on hold on
hold on i gotta break this up okay i
really gotta break this down
jokes aren't allowed anymore no royce
because they contribute to a climate
that results
in police brutality against black people
that sounds like something a [ __ ] would
say and also why is it only blacks right
like i mean i think we could all agree
right there's a hierarchy of how you get
treated by cops i'll admit white people
do
get treated a little bit better by cops
generally speaking in most cases but
like and blacks probably get the worst
of it
but do hispanics get white glove
treatment from the cops
right like do the hispanics get the
[ __ ]
because i've seen hispanics get treated
like absolute dog [ __ ] by the police too
so
racist jokes are done so then all of the
whenever you see like black people on on
facebook and twitter saying man why
people be crazy this stuff the white
people do why people do this why people
do that's fine though right
because you can't be racist that'll be
that'll be fine okay cool because that
you're actually uh attacking people who
have institutional power royce got it
you're punching around jokes stereotypes
no matter how big or small to be offered
in my presence
or what no but i'm gonna ask you a
question here
or what what are you gonna do about it
because this is an aw this is an ominous
statement right are you going to hit me
is that is is that the line that he's
drawing in the ground or or even worse
are you going to cancel me because look
i can take a punch from stanley tucci
you know and i mean i'm not worried
about that i'm i'm more worried about
are you going to use all of your [ __ ]
influence and power to make sure for
instance that people can't process
credit cards
is that what you're going to do
what i want to know is
i i ask because i know we have black we
have black listeners like three of them
and the question i have for them is
you have to you have to be cringing at
this right like
i know if this was me like i'm hispanic
right obviously and
if somebody made a video these a bunch
of [ __ ]
people made a video going we're gonna i
would be like shut the [ __ ] up i could
talk for myself first off i don't need
[ __ ] captain save a hoe over here to
show up you know what i mean i don't
need these white knights to defend my
honor i'll defend myself like i don't
need you this guy comes up to you and
says i won't allow that racial joke
around me what do you do
yeah [ __ ] exactly like shut up
i will not turn a blind eye
going for a job of course not with those
glasses hey by the way you [ __ ] the
few people out there that are sucking
this up because it's trending and i know
it's trending because they're
artificially making a trend but a lot of
people are watching this today and going
wow this is so great i'm going to see it
on my facebook timeline wow did you see
this video these people are so great um
by the way i'm going to say this and
this this is my guess i have no facts
mostly white people
to the people that are going to share
this and and say that they're helping
you understand that these people are
actors right
they're actors
like the whole
their whole job is to go
and i will not allow it
in my presence
i will not
because these sorts of things like this
is what this what they get paid to do
and you're falling for it
should not be a death sentence sleeping
in your own home should not be a death
sentence playing video games with your
nephew should not be a death oh this is
the chick this the chick from broad city
you know that female version of
workaholics that sucked oh yeah yeah
yeah sure really did suck sentence
shopping in a store should not be a
death sentence
business not being able to go to work
for three months because the government
tells you and then you killing yourself
shouldn't have also been a death
sentence but you don't care about that
you don't want to talk about that right
nobody wants to [ __ ] talk about that
right
you know what let me tell you something
going with your mom to mall of america
and shopping and they shouldn't be a
death sentence good thing that kid
survived he was thrown off of a third
story back but you want to talk about
things that shouldn't be a [ __ ] death
sentence that's fine i agree with you
but to pretend like only only one group
of people
is being affected by shitty things is
such a [ __ ] lie
it is such a [ __ ] lie
as usual should not be life-threatening
i stand against hate i stand against
hate
i stand against hate you're reading a
script
some organization i take
responsibility.org
which is probably wrong these puppy
people all probably all have the same
agency representing them so that's
usually what happens when you see stuff
like this
that's usually what happens
they probably wrote a script
and they sent it out and they all read
the script they don't even know what
they're i can't tell you half of these
people don't even know what they're
reading stand against hate i will stand
against hate in love
i will make my presence known what a
bold statement
and killer cops must be prosecuted they
are murderers oh my god this acting is
so cheesy dude
jesse
and that's what i call him jesse listen
buddy
we all
the thing is
before the race riot started happening
i'm sorry if protest started happening
we all agreed that killer cops should be
prosecuted i think most of the country
let's say 90 of the country agreed with
there was there wasn't many people on
the other side of this issue sir
actually oddly enough uh jesse and i'll
call him that as well
um
royce and i were actually very making
very emotional pleas
for believe police brutality to end of
course before you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
jumped on the trend
exactly we were we were talking about it
we didn't get paid a [ __ ] load of money
from amnesty international where the
[ __ ] you got your check from to go this
needs to stop no we just came on our
show and went hey guys you seen this
video wow this [ __ ] needs to stop huh
we can turn the tide where were you
[ __ ] [ __ ] when that lady got shot
in her own house and i was cut we were
all covering that going this needs to
stop
can't just go up to some lady's house
and shoot her through the [ __ ] window
you know uh uh when when uh the [ __ ]
what's his face uh got killed the guy in
his [ __ ] apartment complex
by that blonde chick the drunk one that
just walked in and shot him we were like
wow [ __ ] like this needs to stop
where were you guys
uh
you know i'll tell you where he was
i'll tell you where he was
he was too busy murdering the innocent
man gayle
yeah what about gail what about gay yeah
what about justice for gayle jesse gail
botticker huh he was just a libertarian
that liked to do karaoke like his little
karaoke video and you killed him dead
are you ever gonna pay for that jesse
and what about what about what about the
other murder you committed killing the
breaking bad franchise by making el
camino jesus that really was a murder
what about that jesse you should be put
in prison for that jesse
for agreeing to that
i will you know what i'm all meth damn
i'm on a matt damon site he should be in
a [ __ ] cell eating ice cream yeah you
don't see that fatty on here crying
it is time
to take responsibility
i didn't kill anybody call out hate
okay i already do that next and then
what what else then what what's what
else but jokes too right we can't do
jokes anymore jokes is hate jokes are
out there jokes okay just make it sure
do you understand if you laughed at like
the first cup if you laughed at the the
[ __ ] office you're racist a lot of
racial jokes and that's a lot of them
you're racist you can't do that you're
not allowed
step up
and take action because i'm saying it
like this
and that makes it important i i it's
you guys really buy this
and you do
i know because i see it i see it on my
timeline how many people are going to go
this is so great
i take
responsibility.org why don't we check
out that website let me check out that
website
i
take responsibility
let's see here
let's see
dot
org
i take responsibility.org is not working
oh check it out no no it is working hold
on
guess what this is a this is a a self
white guilt maker
i take responsibility for then your
options are turning a blind eye to
racism making racist jokes explaining
away police brutality saying racism
doesn't exist
explaining systemic racism denying white
privilege exists not educating myself on
racism my own implicit bias against
black people saying i don't see cult
hold on
saying i don't see color is racist now
i don't know anymore so you want people
to be racist i don't know anymore
listening to and believing not listening
to and not believing black people so
they don't they never lie
not being inclusive not educating my
kids on systemic racism
valuing black culture more than black
lives which one do you want to pick
we have to pick one i'm not picking any
of them i'm gonna do making racist jokes
because i will take responsibility for
it but i will not apologize for it so
there you go i will take i am [ __ ]
doing again
and making uh and to make today better i
will
demand for police accountability
support organizations on the front lines
donate to families affected mobilize
voting efforts
wait a second
so you're freely admitting this is
political
your free mobilized voting efforts is is
a way of saying we need to get biden in
the office you're not standing up for
hate or for anything
this is a and it's so carefully crafted
this is another political movement
this is here's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna pick donate to families affected
the families that had their small
businesses ruined see i could do this
there you go get started let's see
get it get get started let me click here
you've pledged to donate to families
affected i run with mod justin for
breanne taylor official george george
ford memorial fund
the bail project the national revolving
bail funds as a mission to combat mass
incarcerations and reshape
pre-trial systems the united states 100
of online donations are used to bring
people home since bail money comes back
okay so basically just go to new york
you can do whatever you want let's see
here let's see uh about let's how about
we look at the team
adam j platzner
tommy oliver cody elaine oliver and john
torner
partners
confidential films naacp sunset cheese
red antler
thank you to these roller thank yous
these are all the thank yous you can
make a pledge you could donate to them
about
uh
uh these people
these [ __ ] it's insufferable it's a
political movement like it always is of
course it is there's nothing pure
anymore
there's and i know that's not i'm not
breaking any ground by making that
statement but there isn't any movement
that's that's think of what's the last
thing that we were actually looked at
that we were completely did politics
didn't just infiltrate i'm talking about
both sides here by the way
no i know what what is i can't think of
it that's why i'm just constantly like
seeking a little corner somewhere that's
that's not
actively political you gotta just stay
moving around like what's the least
political thing this week i'm gonna go
hide out over there and then when they
start politicizing it i'll move